how you feel about this
the interview you your story your view
well
I remember getting an interview before
so I don't know what to think really
is it because you've never wanted to or
because no one has seemingly
expressed interest in your story
well it's mostly because I just never
had the opportunity I think how did you
wind up homeless
simple
I got a bless from Albuquerque back to
L.A
and I didn't have money didn't have
money to uh run a place to live I didn't
have you know a way to get started
so he simply wound up on the sidewalk
and how long ago was that
was in 2000
you've been unhoused for 23 years
yeah I I'm saying 22 going on 23. what
is life on the street like for you
real pain in the neck
because
you don't have a place to live
you you can't just get up take a shower
go to the kitchen fix breakfast have a
cup of coffee read the newspaper and you
know and then start your day
no
your day starts and then you deposit
will open your eyes you throw your
sleeping bag in your backpack now what
do you do
well you don't have anything else to do
for me it's uh go go get you know go get
a cup of coffee
well so go and get a we're gonna get a
couple cups coffee
well
okay there's from there there's nothing
to do
you know or you or you have to go or you
have to go to a soup kitchen
you know and stand in line for for lunch
you know or uh go to the church take a
shower do things like this and it it's
just
it's all sporadic there is no order
you know and I I find it just
a life of disorder yeah
i i find I find it completely confusing
and degrading that's reading actually
because you're you're truly liking just
just another number you're here you get
here in 2000 what did you start doing
did you get a job could you find a job
no
people won't give you a job because you
don't have
in my case being self-employed for 10
years after 10 years with the carnival
I have no I have no verifiable job
references
I have no dress
and at the time no phone number
no point of contact
people are like no they don't want to
hire me
you know and it's because it's because I
don't have the things that everybody
else has it says this person is
employable
even though uh even though it really
doesn't take much to show up on time and
wash dishes for eight hours
it's pretty simple job that now the
employers got they have their standards
and I'm below it
why do you feel like that
because I've been told that really I
have been told go away no you can't have
a job application because you're
homeless
and how does that feel cash
actually if I hear it one more time then
I'm going to melt down
why
because it's wrong
because if I'm actually a human being
I should have the same chances as
everybody else
when did the pain start
the team
actually the team really started in
uh right
right around May of 2022.
I ignored it for several months
up until about December of 2020 what was
hurting going to
actually everything or from here all the
way down to here
you know you taught them a year down to
the bottom of my neck
and it was uh
just really tremendous
nothing I could do about it because
tell me how tremendous it was and what
you would do what people would hear oh
people
it was so bad that I I just screamed
uncontrollably I mean literally
at top of my lungs and people would call
the police because I'm making a nuisance
you know the idea was
get rid of him
well the whole problem there was is I
was trying to get help
through a social worker and things like
this he would take me to the clinic the
clinic would send me to a dermatologist
I had skin cancer and send me to a
dermatologist
then the dermatologists would just say
well just put this cream on it or to
treat these antibiotics which weren't
working
and then I'd be screaming again
the next thing you know is
this then the call name one statement to
the emergency room your health and pain
medication you know you need to go back
to your regular doctor of the clinic
and then go back to another
dermatologist
and this went on for a year you were
like in this washing machine cycle
of just trying to see somebody and
trying to get help and you just kept
going round and round that's that's a
good way to put it because uh actually
there's sometimes when I
I actually didn't feel like I was in
Morrison machine more like a tumble
dryer with it all the way up on high you
know as long as we're going around in
circles let's get hot in here but in
dealing with the terrible set of
circumstances you have had an incredible
amount of kindness shown your way here
lately I sure have and I am grateful for
every bit of it how did that start so
takiana bumped into me
and uh
she uh
she asked if there's anything I could do
I said well nothing really right now
and uh she asked where I was staying I
told her
well she went home and told Carmen
her partner yeah the lovely situation in
fact I was sleeping in a cold slab in
the rain out of church in front of the
church
so Carmen says well let's go get him
and he's come to find out
they showed up about nine o'clock
but I had already taken
I wonder
the strongest pain pills that I had and
I was gone you couldn't wake me no
matter what
so Tatiana just started next morning to
come back
and she caught me I had just taken the
pill and I'd laid back down
so she's like good morning she goes
would you like to come to would you like
to come to my house
and I'm like well
I really don't I'm thinking I really
don't have a choice
I said okay
we'll do that why would you not have a
choice
because uh
between Cancer and exposure to whether I
was going downhill and I knew it
those uh this guy's on the way out
um
so these two women welcome you into
their home right and how was that
actually
it was kind of odd because I'm not used
to sleeping on a bed
yeah the first night I was there I
because I had all my stuff with me
the first night I was there I crawled
crowd of in dead
and I got thinking well maybe I'll get a
well I'll get up and get the sleeping
bag and sleep in that
because the bed didn't feel right yeah
because it felt odd so when the time you
were with them
what did they do for you
very simple
oh you brought me uh
bought me like
three more seussicals
more socks now I got them coming out my
ears three meals a day
I'm used to eating two of them lucky
uh I had a shower every day
you know uh a place to sleep every night
this is all provided by them
it didn't top it all off before I left
you took me to uh took me to Irvine to
see about a car
which uh couldn't find out someone had
donated to the church for me to get a
another car
we wound up one thing and coming home
so much changed in your life just in
those three weeks you were with them oh
yeah absolutely
and it's it's only because of one thing
one thing only
two people that actually care about
somebody
and I don't mean I don't mean nice to
see you God bless you be on your way
no
they really do care
Reverend Jesse Smith
she really cares
my friend Dr Dave neska really cares
the people like these
in my life
I've got I've got a land on my feet
and the fact that Dr savane has been
such a great help you know with with the
cancer treatments and everything else
now I could actually see
I could actually see a brighter much
brighter future how does it feel to have
people treat you
well
you have people treat me well
feels wonderful
because
you you can go just about anywhere
you can be treated like just another
number just another facing the crowd
somebody is not important
seems like anybody in everybody to treat
you like them but the few that actually
treat you like like a real person you
know treat you like you mean something
to them
priceless
thank you
I didn't want to do this story
and have you look like a fish in a
fishbowl that we were just looking at
okay
and I appreciate that because
respect
is a good starting point
you know all this
because if you have respect for somebody
else
you're not going to look at them like
that
that's right
I wanted to do this because
I think we have a lot to learn from the
way these people
have treated you
and I hope other people do learn it
because if we if we can spread the good
around
there's less bad
and
you've
in this probably the only real way
to get rid of the Homeless Problem
surely there will be people who watch
this who say why doesn't he stay at a
shelter
and the reason for that
there's two very good reasons for this
one is I still have open wounds from my
cancer
that's considered a health issue they
will not allow that
and number two
is I have ADHD
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
I am not accepted by other homeless
people
it causes trouble why what do you mean
I'm different than they are
okay I don't drink I don't use drugs
I'm different than New York
so therefore I'm an outcast and they
don't want me in their shelter
yeah and they are very territorial like
that
and it causes trouble and it causes a
lot of trouble I've been in quite some
Shockers you feel like people look at
you and think you're mentally ill
because you're homeless
the average person
will look at someone who is homeless and
will see someone who
who drinks too much we'll see a drug
addict we'll see someone who's mentally
ill
because he won't take the time to even
bother to say hello
you won't take time to strike up a
conversation with you
so your automatically labeled what is it
going to take
for you to become housed
on your feet
and no longer on the street well it's
gonna it's gonna take a lot of work yes
that's one thing for sure
because now that I have another car uh
yes
this cancer stuff is uh
is cleared up
I intend on going back to work for
doordash
that'll give me some type of an income
but with the
prices of rent around here
I don't know what I can afford and so it
occurred to me between Carmen and
Tatiana Reverend Jesse your friend the
retired doctor there's also been a
merry-go-round and this human chain
of kindness
that's that's the that's the best
Merry-Go-Round to be on yeah because
what I can see is
a lot of good things and no side effects
yeah
yeah how much money do you have now
right now I got about twenty dollars
you know I got about twenty dollars and
three quarters of tank yes
not too bad
I've been in worse shape
I'm switching back into the car right
now
and uh
you know it's because I'm still in
transition Pace because I have to I have
to get through cancer treatments before
I can uh
before I can start back up with doordash
do you feel like there is hope
for you
I certainly feel more hope now than than
I did
than I did a month ago
you know it's like
is a month month ago is like you know
will somebody just hurry up and pulled a
plug on me and just get it over with
because I was just exhausted
you know no it's
there's a lot more hope I mean I can see
myself getting better now yeah I can see
myself
I received myself getting back to doing
some type of meaningful work
you know
that I find very helpful
how has this interview been for you
actually
fun good the reason why I say that
it's because I finally had a chance to
say what's on my lane for a change
instead of just like
what why tell you anything you wouldn't
even listen
you know a lot of other people's like
well I tell you you people don't listen
you know finally I had a chance to see
what I needed to say